schock am späten abend gestern in
leipzig ein fähiger junger war plötzlich
spurlos verschwunden
die polizei suchte mit einem
großaufgebot nach dem kind und fand es
dann tatsächlich in einer straßenbahn
zunächst kam es auch zu einer festnahme
der mann ist mittlerweile aber wieder
auf freiem fuß
gegen 18.30 kam aus dem süden der stadt
leipzig einen vermisstenfall auf bei der
polizei hat sich die familie eines
vierjährigen jungen gemeldet
sofort rückte ein großaufgebot der
polizei an auch ein hubschrauber wurde
eingesetzt um den jungen zu finden da
war noch völlig unklar was passiert ist
offensichtlich war er noch beim spielen
draußen und wurde dort von einem mann
entführt
wir stehen jetzt hier ungefähr sieben
kilometer entfernt von der stelle wo er
verschwunden ist an der könneritzstraße
an einer straßenbahnhaltestelle
hier gab es dann den zugriff genau der
zugriff wie ist dieser dann erfolgt das
kind konnte an gott sei dank sehr
schnell gefunden werden
es gab nach diesem vermisstenfall
nachdem nachdem erst nichts gefunden
wurde rund um einen see auch in dem
wohngebiet einen sogenannten sammle ruf
bei den leipziger verkehrsbetrieben das
funktioniert so dass die leitstelle der
verkehrsbetriebe sich über funk an die
fahrer in den straßenbahnen wendet eine
genaue personenbeschreibung durch gibt
und einen straßenbahnfahrer im
fahrgastraum der hatte gerade feierabend
ist dann der junge ausgibt aufgefallen
und er hat sich sofort bei der
leitstelle gemeldet und die linie
durchgegeben linie 1 war dass die kamen
dann gegen 22 uhr erfolgte das dann
nachdem die straßenbahnfahrerin hier
angefangen ist an die haltestelle die
türen verschlossen gelassen hielt bis
die polizei kam auch ein hubschrauber
war hier dann wieder mit im einsatz und
der zugriff erfolgte dann relativ
schnell
der mann wurde herausgezogen zum
polizeiauto gebracht und richtung die
wir gefahren jetzt aber wieder
freigelassen er solle nicht der
entführer gewesen sein gibt es
irgendeine spur jetzt dazu wie der junge
oder mit wem der junge erst mal
verschwunden war
im moment haben wir da noch gar keine
informationen in den nächsten stunden
möchten polizei und staatsanwaltschaft
damit an die öffentlichkeit gehen die
versuchen natürlich jetzt auch diesen
fall zu klären
auch die der mann vielleicht mit dem
jungen in verbindung stehen
könnte ist alles noch unklar moment mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schau dir hier das nächste video an
und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren